rather than hotels and that got the sort
of reception you'd expect and Sparks the
latest Row in the PM's campaign to stop
the boats and there were fireworks at
Deputy pmqs today with the latest round
between Dominic Raab and Angela Rayner
it's always fiery with those two so
plenty to get stuck into as we bring you
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes
accommodation for migrants should meet
their essential living needs and nothing
more
well that was the immigration Minister
Robert generick promising even tougher
policies on Asylum Seekers and earlier
in the Commons we had the battle of the
deputies
the Deputy Prime Minister knows
firsthand the misery cause by Thugs and
they're intimidating Behavior
lurking
Ness
exploding in fits of Rage creating a
culture of fear and maybe even I don't
know throwing things
her labor is Angela Rayner enjoying
causing maximum discomfort to the Deputy
Prime Minister Dominic Raab that's over
the upcoming report into bullying claims
against him but he did fight back
the speaker I can reassure the house
I've never called anyone scum
and that was a reference there to Angela
Rayner's once Infamous choice of noun to
describe conservatives safe to say there
were no punches pulled with their bosses
absent this lunch time we've got lots of
guests on the show for you coming up
including the education secretary Julian
Keegan's my first interview with her at
Labor's Shadow on forces Minister Luke
Pollard will also be on the program plus
we'll speak to Stuart Jose of the SMP
big week with the new first Minister
much more coming up besides on for take
foreign
[Music]
it's been a busy week we've got a new
first Minister and SMP leader Hamza
Yusuf a PM in Westminster leaning into
the war on small boats despite all the
legal wranglings and a box office Deputy
pmqs as the party leaders were at the
funeral of Betty boothford the first and
only female speaker personally my
favorite ever interviewee well let's
crack straight on shall we we're going
to start with the best bits of the week
so far I will be a first Minister for
all of Scotland that I will work every
minute of every day to earn and to
re-air your respect and your trust
yusuf's Victory here in Edinburgh was
extremely narrow he now needs to Pivot
his position to appeal to The Wider
public Jeremy corbyn is said to be
blocked from standing as a labor
candidate at the next general election
basically ask you if you're thinking of
standing as an independent Mr Corbin
very much I'm going to the demonstration
against the immigration bill and I
suggest you report that too we are
reporting it it will take 10 seconds
thank you very much I just want to talk
to you for 10 seconds about your future
as a life thank you very much now the
government uh today confirmed plans to
put thousands of Asylum seekers in
disused military bases accommodation for
migrants should meet their essential
living needs and nothing more don't
think it's going to solve the problem I
don't think it's going to see people on
barges instead of hotels I don't think
is going to bring the hotel bills down
it's going to add to the cost on the
on the behavior does he think More
Bullies will be brought to Justice
speaker I can reassure the house I've
never called anyone scum King Charles
and the queen consort have been welcomed
to Germany this afternoon it's the first
state visit since the start of the new
monarchs reign
well there's your usual run through
other weeks so far we can hear now from
the government just a little earlier
today I spoke to the education secretary
Jillian Keegan and I started by asking
about the new approach to housing Asylum
Seekers
so you're announcing plans to try and
stop housing migrants in hotels when do
you expect to be able to say that look
no more people are going to be in these
hotels well clearly what we need to do
is get enough accommodation so that's
been what the focus has been and I don't
think hotels were ever meant to be long
term and clearly at a cost of six
million pounds a day they're definitely
not meant to be long term I mean that's
taxpayers money so but we have been
trying to you know work on getting more
accommodation so I think what we're
trying to do now is get ahead of the
plan so we've got four major sites and
then we'll look at also other options as
well so no date then really that you can
you can give us they'll be working on
dates I can't give you a date but
they'll be working on you know when
they're going to try and get enough you
know accommodation we know that the the
we need enough accommodation and you
know that's what I know my colleague
Robert jamrick's been working on is it
really suitable to house families
children even in disused military sites
you're comfortable with that well
obviously we need to make sure that they
are you know they're decent they're
clean
um you know and they're they're a decent
accommodation but I think it is you know
it's it's a basic offer but it is uh an
offer that I think is is you know is is
is decent enough as it were what does
decent enough mean well it's got you
know with the facilities that you need
it's clean you know it's uh it's it's
maybe not luxurious but it's certainly
um you know safe and decent and clean
are you expecting legal challenges on
this
I mean we have lots of legal challenges
in this space but um and that's part of
you know part of the problem has been
delaying you know some aspects of the
longer term Solutions as well which is
uh there are the Rwanda solution for
things that are coming going there yeah
well those that are coming here
illegally obviously that is the plan no
I mean we did win the case in the in the
in the court you know the high court but
of course it's now on appeal so we still
need to go through those legal
challenges but there have been a number
of legal challenges which have held us
up yes okay uh now I just want to talk
to you about strikes because this is
what so many of our viewers are going to
be really impacted by whether they've
got children at school of course seeing
the school closures that we've seen due
to strike action now you've offered
teachers what you're describing as a
final offer pay deal what what exactly
is it well it's what I've offered it's a
fair and reasonable offer is how I've
described it so what we asked to do is
we ask the teachers to pause their
strikes and the teachers union there's
only one teachers union actually the Neu
that are on strike and we ask them to
pause their strikes actually the same
time as the nurses and come in and have
those talks about you know what we could
offer and what we did is we opened up
again the 22-23 pay after after we'd
agreed you know the independent pay
review body
um you know their recommendations
um they didn't accept that straight away
so they had five more days of strikes
which are really disappointing and they
are disruptive to children and they are
disruptive to parents as well and you
know we're very concerned about that
because said about kids that need to
catch up can say and about exam cohort
success what just be Crystal Clear what
is the offer on the table the offer is
so we've reopened 2223 it's a thousand
pounds for every school teacher and
school leader
um so that is a one-off payment it's
worth a different percentage depending
on where you are but it's 1 000 pounds
for all and then for the 23 24
um pay which we would normally go to an
independent payment view body we've
offered 4.5 percent and the inflation
period at that time obviously the obr
have done a forecast as part of the
budget so that goes from September 23 to
to 24. it's not as much inflation it's
less than two percent is that period
it's not as much as I got in Scotland as
it they've been offered a seven percent
rise between April 2022 and March 2023 5
between April and December 2023 and then
a two percent increase why are teachers
in Scotland worth well we've said all
along that we are not trying to you know
match the Scottish or what we have very
different pay structures and they're
very different roles as well so we you
know we we have our own responsibilities
and clearly here the Batman constructs
in different roles I mean like most
teachers would think like you're in
schools you you deserve it yeah but the
pay structures are actually quite
complex you know it's not just everybody
talks about these headline figures
there's actually a lot of progression
pay so actually this is actually what
you're 44 more um for more
um established teachers is actually
lower than those of new starters as well
isn't it so no I mean it depends on
where you are there's progression pay as
well it is actually much more complex
with with the you know it's the headline
figures are what you talk about but the
offer we've made is one thousand pounds
lump sum and 4.5 when
um average earnings are predicted to be
2.3 and inflation is predicted to be
below two so I think that's a fair and
reasonable offer I mean obviously it's
the UK government we have the
responsibility for the economy we've got
the responsibility of halving inflation
we've got the responsibility of making
sure we get that fair balance between
the taxpayer who obviously pays for this
and you know the public sector workers
so we we alone have that balance to do I
want to you mentioned that average pay
and I do think it's important to compare
what teachers are seeing as opposed to
other professions as well because what
some teachers unions would argue is that
look they've had a long time of squeezed
pain I think we can just have a look
quickly now this is the office for
National statistics real-time pay Rises
is 2011. you can see train drivers and
then the private sector the public
sector nurses and all the way down at
the bottom is Teachers you can see why
they'll be feeling a little bit hard
done by if you looked at that going back
to 20 2012. yeah so the point that they
make is they've been a couple of years
over this period where teachers didn't
get a pay rise so I think there was a
couple of years in you know the
beginning when obviously there was no
money left as it were as the note said
and then there was I think a right a a
period in the pandemic as well when
obviously we decided to put public
resources to the fellow scheme this is
comparing to other Prof Fashions right
train drivers nurses things in the
public sector these are all facing the
same cost pressures right yeah but
people are teachers people have
different they're all different on
different salaries and they all have
different terms and conditions and they
all have different progression pay as
well so they're all very different so
they are quite difficult to compare but
the point they're making is there was a
few years where they didn't get pay rise
and if you add up real term Rises then
they want to to make up for that but
that's why we've said I mean this year
we've governed an extra thousand pounds
and that's why if you look at the 4.5
that we've offered for next year
inflation during that period uh
September to September is expected to be
way below two percent well I mean that
will start placing above inflation
inflation last month actually at strip
what many people were obviously wanting
a few price expect inflation which you
know is a lot of what people we know
we've had a spike in inflation salaries
in inflation we know the reasons why we
know all the individual drivers so do
the obr and the obr obviously have made
their forecast and that's all we can
take to be honest that's you know
they're the forecasts that we're using
to try and you know we're predicting
into the future right this is a pay rise
for the future and that's what the
independent pay review body predicting
to do prediction to the Future as well
you've got to teach a recruitment crisis
Brewing right if you look at the
national Foundation of educational
research the target for Teacher
recruitment for next year is 100 there's
only going to be 79 of the primary
school teachers needed and 58 of the
secondary school teachers sounds like a
crisis waiting to happen so what we did
um in Recruitment and it is obviously
vital that you recruit the best you're
worried about this surely your education
secretary you must be looking at these
figures and taking a step back thinking
oh my goodness absolutely so that's why
we put in place bursaries so actually
it's not all equal across all subjects
and it's not equal we have had post
pandemic yeah there's if you look at
Classics in physical education that's
okay but actually if you look at like
Primary School teachers if you look at
Primary School usually is okay this is
the first time because we've got we've
got this dislocated labor impact post
the pandemic so there are every single
everything from heavy Goods drivers to
nurses pretty much everything to
restaurants everything there is a a
shortage of Wages that's why the whole
bunch of salary only one of these
professions teachers are children but
what all of those that's why the whole
budget was really aimed at getting more
people back into work and to to making
sure that we've got the people to grow
however you're right we need to recruit
the best teachers we need to retain the
best teachers and I 100 committed to do
that so when we we put in place a
retention and recruitment strategy we've
also said we will look to update that as
well because clearly you can't have a
first-class world-class education system
without fantastic teachers so 100 and
I've done this many times you know my
long business career I've long long lots
of times had to face you know Workforce
shortages or skills challenges and you
have to put a plan in place the plan in
place includes bursaries it also
includes increasing graduates out
calories as well to make it competitive
and so we have bursaries up to 29 000
pounds in place for some of these
subject areas so we're not sat there
ignoring this but there is a pandemic
impact as well
um I asked if people had questions for
you before the interview and a lot of
people were asking how can schools fund
a pay rise when you're not getting any
new money so Rob poison assistant head
teacher how does she expect any school
to fund a pay rise for staff without
implementing redundancies schools are
operating with skeleton staff as it is
we can't recruit Megan Pacey who works
in early childhood education how can
schools many team budgets are in deficit
or near deficit and who rely on
fundraising to provide basic Learning
Materials like art resources and books
how can they pay for the desperately
needed seller increases on an unfended
basis this is absolutely a fair question
so when I first started the job which
was the end of October what waiting for
me was a letter from all the unions
actually saying to fund the pay Rises
that the independent pay review body had
recommended 5.4 percent
um on average for 22.23 obviously we've
now uh added a thousand pounds to that
they said we need two billion pounds
extra and to our other inflationary
pressures as well you know energy costs
Etc so the very first thing I had to do
within two weeks of the job was to go to
the chancellor for the Autumn statement
and get two billion pounds extra for
this year for next year now that is
we've secured that it will be going into
schools budget shortly so there is extra
money coming now that is for you know
those terrorizers that are agreed but
they've already agreed now on top of
that what we've said is we will fully
fund the 1 000 pounds because that's uh
not going to be within those budgets
because of where the the other things
that budget School budgets are looking
at so in particular energy costs we
think that the school budgets and the
ifs actually have confirmed this as well
can probably fund up to about four
percent of next year's pay rise but that
leaves half a percent Delta so in total
if I take those two together that would
be 620 million pounds extra that I would
have to find new money for schools so
and we've said that we've committed to
that I mean clearly schools we don't
expect them to to give head teachers the
problem of a thousand pounds for
everybody but not knowing how to fund it
so we will be funding that and I think
it's really important because if I look
at Twitter which I try not to but I
sometimes have to but if you look at
Twitter if you look at other things I
don't think and listen to those
questions most people seem to have
missed the two billion pounds that was
fully funded the last time the fact that
people haven't missed people haven't
missed the the money that was given in
the Autumn statement this is additional
cost pressures on schools that they have
to try and find in addition to the money
that was given before and let's not
forget of course it hasn't actually gone
yet schools I've had it's been announced
a decade it's been announced they
haven't had it in their budget they've
had a decade of what many would describe
as underfunding I'm just wondering can I
just I'd like to pick you up on that
point because if you listen to the ifs
they've now said with the additional the
additional yeah because the additional
graphic from the ifs so this is the
school funding percentage of change per
pupil since you can see the line 2010
when the conservatives first enter power
and you can see the private schools line
in blue and the state's calls line in
red and I think it stops a year early so
if you go up to where we would be now
all the money was announced my point
which is we're talking about the decade
of what many people will describe as
underfunding well if you if you look at
this line I think it is really an
important line to look at there was one
bump a year which is 2010. so that year
just as they were leaving office there
was a huge rise in the budget it wasn't
there all the way through it was this
huge rise and then of course we they
left us with no money but if you take
this now to where we are today we are
now back 58.8 billion pounds which is
the highest we've ever funded schools in
history so it is important to say that
because as okay as of this next year
that's that extra 2 billion when it's
added to the budget that's where it will
be do you and is it you know you you've
got answers to all the questions you've
got lots of and you know stats to throw
you saying that these these can't be
compared this is the equivalent over do
you get how worried your parents are
right now you know the teachers are
striking kids are not in school many of
them who've missed time from Junior
pandemic they're looking at school
funding and they're worried
they shouldn't worry about the school
funding because the money with extra
money even the teachers who parents are
being asked to like fund things like art
supplies paper like 58.8 billion pounds
is a lot of money we spend in our
schools so they shouldn't be worried
about that okay and and the extra money
is coming for the budget but the most
important thing is I want teachers to
know because they'll be having to ballot
on this now they'll be having to vote
the 1 000 pounds and the 4.5 percent you
know there will be extra funding to make
sure that schools can afford that and if
we don't have this agreement which you
know we've done our best we've I mean I
spent almost a couple of weekends ago
with them we've you know gone till early
hours Etc to try and thrash out as much
as we can then what we will do is we'll
go to the independent pay review process
they will come up with something for
23.24 but they won't come up with
anything for 20 to 23 so okay it is
important that they know that because it
is funded and I do want them to have it
we are out of time there are so much
stuff that I want to talk to you about
not least your own background you know a
bunch of comprehensive school started
apprenticeship at 16 and so hopefully
get and I really care about this Sofia
and the reason I know all the facts and
figures is because I want to be fair I
don't want you know I want to know if
it's actually are we funded schools
enough are kids going to get best
education and I think are we paying
teachers enough to make sure that we get
enough teachers and the answer to those
questions because people will have very
different views on but thank you very
much thank you thank you Sophie
uh well a bit later on we'll get labels
at taking all that but let's talk first
shall we to uh Deputy place at Sam
Coates watching that interview what was
your what was your takeaway Sam
well
um
it was difficult watch actually
um what you're very conscious of is an
education secretary who sort of flings a
whole load of figures at you but I do
wonder whether the figures that she uses
are particularly Fair comparative so a
large part of the interview with the
education secretary was about the pay
deal for teachers the government has
made one it's not been accepted by the
unions there is still a prospect of of
more strikes and Jillian Keegan was
making the argument that next year there
will be inflation at about two two to
three percent according to most of the
forecasts and so the government offer of
a thousand pound lump sum plus 4.2
percent uh as a pay rise for this year
is more than adequate but
some might think incredible argument
given that inflation this year is
upwards of 10 so prices will be 10
higher this year and then a further two
percent higher uh the year after and the
answer from the government is is four
point two percent plus a thousand pounds
some in the way that she talks about the
other I can see
um perhaps for political opponents does
does give some rise the the way that she
casually Compares teachers to delivery
drivers and says well you know there is
a shortage in some areas of teaching but
there's a sausage in delivery drivers to
I mean I I just invite viewers to make
their own judgment I think think there's
also you know I found it quite striking
when she was saying that parents
shouldn't worry about school budgets
that they've been given a lot of money
and that they should not worry they've
got nothing to worry about when it comes
to school budgets and again I just
wonder if that really meets with some
people's lived experience of what is
going on in schools at the minute and
the funding pressures that schools are
coming under and I do accept that look
from the government's perspective it was
the Health Service and it was schools
that was prioritized in that Autumn
statement right in November but then at
the same time to say there's nothing to
worry about in terms of budgets
um that does feel like quite a strong
statement to make yeah no I think
there's a whole question an interesting
question for Spin Doctors about tone
there was another section of the
interview where drinking sort of
suggested that you didn't understand
very much about the concept of
progression pay where as people move
through the ranks that their their pay
goes up which I thought was an
interesting uh technique to use I mean
if it's straightforward please do
explain it to uh to viewers I'm sure
they'll understand I I think more
generally the questions who did the
education secretary sound like she was
on the side of it wasn't the unions but
it wasn't particularly the teachers it
wasn't particularly parents either it's
sort of a sort of rather spreadsheet
first treasury approach uh uh you know
justifying uh limited resource and
perhaps not
speaking to what for many parents is an
incredibly important priority which is
proper funding of the education system
for the for children so that Britain
their families and Britain can be a
better place in the future and I guess a
takeaway from the interview in many ways
is that look it does seem like the
education secretary and the unions are
pretty far apart right now which means
more strike action potentially uh Sam
thanks for your take we'll have more
from Sam later on the program you're
watching the take we're live in
Westminster up next we're going to be
talking to Labor's Shadow Armed Forces
Minister Luke Pollard
[Music]
thank you
big stories don't always come from big
cities
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's Midlands
correspondent and this is where I grew
up we can reveal that the driver who hit
Harry Dunn is 42 year old am circulus
just met the president and we never
thought we'd get this far this is what
they're up against that the wind is the
really big problems it is back breaking
work and the smoke is thick
working well water levels are dropping
but no one knows what impact further
rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world it's really scary
we're terrified in this community I'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid hopefully this will be
the last wave
I never knew they would make it
amazing
tantalizingly close in this corner of
the UK Wales was the first to introduce
the plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back to Westminster
watching the take and up next we can get
the view from labor because a bit
earlier I spoke to the party's Shadow
Armed Forces Minister that's Luke
Pollard
you are looking into a campaign about
military housing what's the idea well
the basic premise is that everyone who
serves in our Armed Forces should be
living in a decent quality home but we
know that Armed Forces personnel and
their families are living on military
bases and in the community in military
housing that is leaky with leaky roofs
broken boilers and black mold in
bedrooms now this problem has been
getting worse over recent years with
private contractors hired by the
military defense paid a fortune but not
repairing these properties and that is
leading directly to people feeling that
they want to leave the services but at
this very moment we need a stronger set
of armed forces and with one in four
Armed Forces Personnel saying that poor
accommodation is increasing their
intention to leave the Armed Forces
that's a really serious problem that we
need to get to grips with and what
Labor's been saying is the 13 years of
Tory government have not got to grips
with it but the next Labor government
will make this a priority so we can fix
it so every one of our Armed Forces and
their families get to live in a decent
quality accommodation military
accommodation is obviously in the news
today as well because the government is
talking about potentially housing
migrants in disused military sites
do you think that's a good policy well I
don't think it's going to work because
fundamentally it doesn't fix the
problems with our immigration system
didn't ask if it was going to work but
in principle do you think it's a good
policy it's good enough for soldiers is
it good enough for people who come to
our Shores trying to claim Asylum well
they're not being used for the military
at the moment so they're not moving
soldiers or RAF Personnel out of the
Barrack blocks and moving Asylum seekers
in many cases these are bases that have
been closed for many years and might be
used for different purposes in the
meantime but it doesn't deal with the
fundamental problem in the fact that the
Asylum system is broken it takes too
long for decisions to be made in fact
actually we know the number of decisions
about Asylum cases is actually falling
with a really slow response rate so that
means that we're not able to either
Grant Asylum for those people who have
an eligible case fast enough or
importantly remove those people who
don't have an eligible case because we
haven't got return agreements with our
nearest neighbors France and the rest of
the European Union and the government's
not being tough enough on those criminal
gangs so it's dealing with the
consequences of broken policy rather
than trying to fix it at source which
they really should be I'm just trying to
get my head around whether you disagree
with the government's policy in
principle or if you just think the
implementation is wrong so it's the
speed at which the applied Asylum system
uh is is working or whether or not it's
about whether you can get a returns
agreement uh in place with countries
around the world at our nearest
neighbors as well or is it in principle
do you think that look we should be more
welcoming towards as Island Seekers we
should be letting more people in which
is it well at the moment we have too
many Asylum Seekers and not enough
accommodation for them so there has to
be a way of housing people that are
coming to the UK and claiming Asylum but
the fundamental problem is wherever you
put them if you're not having an
immigration system that can make
decisions sensibly and last year they
made a decision that only one percent of
Asylum cases so this isn't about a
marginal gain here and there this is
about a fundamental failure of the
government to make proper decisions on
Asylum cases and no matter how much
tweaking around the edge and dealing
with the consequences of a broken system
if you don't get to the root causes
that's the criminal gangs that are
profiting from those dangerous Crossings
across the channel and the fact that the
government can't make quick enough
decisions to have a system that works so
what Labor's arguing is that we should
be fast tracking those people that are
claiming Asylum from safe countries
Albania for instance by fast tracking
those decisions you could be clearing
much of the Asylum backlog so you can
actually then be spending the time on
those cases that do deserve proper
scrutiny and proper support for those
individuals that are fleeing war and
conflicts that's not where we are at the
moment so this looks to me like just
another headline grabbing initiative
which is there to divert attention from
the fact that the system is
fundamentally failing where do you think
people should be housed then what they
shouldn't be housed in um in hotels
because that is far too expensive for
the public it doesn't provide the
support and certainty for the people who
have fled war and famine and so
realistically you can we can have an
argument about where the huge numbers of
people should be housed now and there is
probably a case for looking at different
varieties I'm not convinced putting
people on a barge is the right answer so
not hotels not barges what's the idea
then where should they go but the way to
deal with that is by dealing with the
backlog is by processing the claims
they've got to go somewhere in the
meantime though aren't they well in the
meantime they are going into hotels we
know from the government announcement
yesterday that those people who served
with our armed forces in Afghanistan who
have been given sanctuary in the UK who
are in hotels currently are going to be
evicted by the government in three
months time but that's not the same
Focus policy they're applying to Asylum
Seekers so it seems that if you serve
with our Armed Forces you're getting a
rougher deal from this government than
if you came over on a small boat because
the system's not working to process
those claims I mean this is a mess
Sophie and that's the fundamental
problem on this if we don't fix it at
source if we don't help keep more people
in their countries by making uh safer
Arrangements creating safe routes so
people with a genuine case can legally
come to the country and then have their
claims processed not in many years but
in a small number of months which is
what we should be aiming for well that
would clear up the backlog that would
reduce the impact on communities and
last night in the Commons labor tabled
amendments to the legal immigration bill
that would have allowed local
communities to have a bigger say on that
extra temporary accommodation in their
own communities now Tory MPS voted
against that but now we have Tory MPS
who are finding out today that their own
communities are having additional Asylum
Seeker accommodation placed on former
military sites where their communities
get no say it doesn't seem that the
system's working and we spoke to Jillian
Keegan the education secretary a little
bit earlier on the program and she was
talking about the offer made to teachers
she thinks it's a reasonable one she
also said that people shouldn't worry
parents shouldn't worry about school
funding because the additional money
that was given in the Autumn statement
is she right well I would like people
not to worry about their kids education
because after the years of disruption we
know that our kids have suffered quite a
lot but the Press pressures that
teachers are under the cost of living
crisis it really means that teachers
have a valid concern about where they
are and I think ministers need to sit
down much more with them well they have
been sitting down with them haven't they
they haven't really got anywhere right
but to sit down there's a simple Act of
sitting around a table and there's the
act of sitting down and genuinely
listening and trying to find a solution
offer more money to teachers well I
can't make spending commitments
especially this far out from a general
election but I think what the government
could be doing is genuinely listening to
the case and trying to find a solution
here in the way that they haven't really
been as enthused to do now when
ministers have sat down with unions in
other sectors for instance if they
generally listen if they put away their
Hyperbole and their big stick and say
okay let's have a mature conversation
about how we can resolve this because
teachers and nurses are not the bad guys
it's not just the mature conversation
they want though is it they want money
right that's the stepping point they
have been sitting around the table both
sides have got there on the table and
they just can't agree on money that's a
problem
it is um and that's where good
negotiations uh properly work because in
these situations you resolve strike
action by proper negotiation and that's
where ministers should be around the
table taking the time to understand the
true consequences especially for those
people in teaching who are on low
salaries those people starting out in
teaching For Whom the cost of living
crisis is acutely felt for them okay now
um this week of course kistama has waded
into a bit of a row with Jeremy corbyn
who's been barred from standing as a
labor candidate and I just want to read
a quote to you the attacks on Jeremy
corbyn on the election we just had were
terrible and they came back at us on the
doors they vilified him and they knew
what they were doing and they knew why
they were doing it Jeremy corbyn being
vilified I mean it feels like that could
be a quote from John McDonnell or diabet
about kirstalmer recently but that was
actually starmer himself the labor
leadership hostings back in 2020.
guess my question isn't you know about
rehashing the argument about whether or
not Jeremy corbyn is fit to stand as a
labor MP my question is about care
Starlight because it feels like he's
changed his mind on Jeremy corbyn
despite the fact that everything we knew
about Jeremy corbyn then we know now
yeah um I think he has made the right
decision here because he's also given
Jeremy the opportunity to apologize for
his remarks around anti-Semitism that
Jeremy chose not to and a route back
into the Parliamentary party if he had
taken it now Jeremy corbyn chose not to
do that I don't think Jeremy's the
future of the labor party I think we've
moved on as a party and labor now looks
unrecognizable from the party that
Jeremy led a few years ago Starman looks
unrecognizable as well then because he
was obviously around the shadow cabinet
table telling everyone that they should
vote for him is the next prime minister
but what's happened since then is we've
had the ehrc report that looked at
anti-Semitism in a labor party that
highlighted the utter failings of our
party to deal with anti-Semitism Kier
said on day one of his leadership that
that would be the yard stick to assess
his leadership against he would take
Serious action that's what he has done
Jeremy had a choice about how to respond
to that animation and I'm afraid he
chose uh poorly and chose to continue
some of those uh uh some of that
language that has helped uh that was
designed to downplay anti-Semitism well
anti-Semitism should have no place in
low party and no place in politics in
general and if you can't call out
anti-Semitism clearly without without
um without qualifying it then you
shouldn't be a labor MP and that's what
key is made very clear to all the
Parliamentary party and that's what
laborers national executive committee
have made clear for anyone wishing to
stand as a labor candidate at the next
general election okay thank you for
watching thank you
we'll get a bit more analysis of Labor
Sam coats has actually put exhaust chat
GPT the AI the artificial intelligence
program uh what the next labor party
Manifesto is going to look like so we'll
find the answer to that later on the
program you're watching the take live in
Westminster up next though we are going
to be talking about their new first
minister in Scotland Hamza Yusuf with
the S P's economy spokesperson here in
Westminster
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take now on Monday
the s p elected a new leader Hunter
Youssef narrowly defeated Cape Forbes to
take over from Nicholas sturgeon and
yesterday he was voted in as first
minister in the Scottish Parliament and
today he appointed his cabinet well now
I can speak to the S P's economy
spokesperson here in Westminster that's
Stuart Hosey good to have you with us so
Hamza Yousaf a new first Minister new
leader of the s p
no surprise really that he got the job
but was a bit closer than you thought it
was going to be I wasn't quite sure
where it was going to be at the end but
uh you know it was pretty close between
him and Kate second preferences came in
52-48 that number again that number
again uh both Kate and Ash Reagan were
very gracious uh after it was announced
and Hamza has got to work very quickly
he's been appointed first Minister he's
appointed the cabinet today I've only
just seen the list of the minor
positions I haven't committed those to
memory yet but it's actually pretty
exciting why do you think it's exciting
then well if you look at the cabinet
you've got an extraordinary mix of
really talented relatively young people
Mari gujjon Mari McAllen Jenny gold Ruth
you've got people like Sean Roberson and
others who've been there for a long time
and know the parliament you've got Angus
Roberts and still there as the cabinet
secretary for the Constitution there's a
man who was the Westminster leader of
the SNP down here for years he knows his
way around UK politics I think this is a
really really strong team
the person whose name you might have
expected to be there who is not there is
Kate Forbes right who ran yeah very a
strong campaign she finished a close
second she was offered the rural Affairs
brief I mean that's a bit like
constructive dismissal or some words
though uh no she was offered the cabinet
secretary rule for Rural Affairs and a
bunch of other things this is a full
rule in government she didn't feel like
she could accept it though she didn't
feel like she could accept it but today
the comments she's made about Hamza and
about the team who have been appointed
have been absolutely first class I I
think what it would say is I know a lot
of our political opponents are trying to
make Mischief with this and of course I
understand that I don't think this is
quite the story they think they are just
looking
such a gracious you know statement on
Twitter that s are the new first
Minister offered his main rival a job
that she felt was too Junior to accept
and that's why she's decided to go to
the batmanches that is why well I I'm
not going to second guess the reasons
why she turned that rule down but she
was offered a full job in government
quite right to she has chosen for her
own reasons not to take it and she's
been extremely gracious today in terms
of the way homeless has gone about his
business appointing the cabinet do you
accept that there is a job at hand to
unite the s p after what was clearly a
pretty fractious campaign of course
there is and it would be naive to say it
wasn't but let me put it this way Hamza
is only the fifth individual to lead the
asmp in 40 years and this is the first
contested leadership election we've had
in two decades and I'll be really honest
I'm not surprised it was a bit Spacey
but that contest is now over Unity is
now vital we'll have a UK election in 18
months with an independence campaign to
take up through the gears and of course
with the government to run so I'm pretty
confident you will see the unity and the
discipline the SNP are Fame for
returning rather quickly okay we'll have
to say the uh you know the proof is on
the pudding on that one um if I may well
I've got you I'm just Keen to talk to
you about a kind of lead political story
uh today in Westminster and that is the
government's plans to try and move away
from using what they were describe as
expensive hotels to house at migrant
scene do you think that's a policy
that's a sensible I have to say the
whole immigration policy whether it's
the pushing back the boats dog whistle
nonsense whether it's putting people up
in Old barges
it's obscene and it makes no sense
if the government was serious about
taking on the people's smuggles and the
human traffickers all we would hear
about would be intelligence and Joint
policing and board the fourths
improvements we hear little or none of
that it's all dog whistle rhetoric about
pushing back boats but isn't some of the
reason we don't hear about that because
it's actually really hard to do if you
look at Interpol for example you know
they say look actually get into the
people Smugglers is one of the most
difficult crimes to crack because the
relationship they have it's very
transient people don't know The
Smuggler's real name they use burner
phones I mean it's very easy you know
for politicians to say look I'm just
going to click my fingers and we're
going to smash the gang you know I I
don't think it's as easy as snapping
fingers and smashing gangs I'm not that
naive but one can only imagine with the
resources of French government and the
UK government and the channel is rather
narrow that they can track boats they
can trace the boats they know where
people are leaving from lots of the
stuff done on the internet and I think
there's to be an awful lot more effort
if that's the intention
to go for these people directly rather
than punishing refugees and this is the
thing that I find most obscene in the
SNP find
extraordinarily obscene
refugees and Asylum Seekers are being
demonized it's not illegal to be a
refugee it's not illegal to be an asylum
Seeker it's not illegal to come to the
UK to seek Asylum there needs to be a
bit more respect a bit more a
acknowledgment of international law that
we're a country people want to come to
for their safety respect that rather
than this demonization of people who are
really desperate okay thank you very
much indeed
uh well that was a student housing or
the sap a very big week of course for
his party and it's been a big week for
campaigners as well now when we spoke to
Carol Gould who's a mother of the
murdered teenager Ellie Gould just three
days ago that's on Sunday she was
hopeful that the government would
significantly increase sentences for
those who violently kill women we now
know thanks to a letter from Dominic
Robb that they're only planning to add
around two years for aggravating factors
like the use of excessive or gratuitous
violence beyond that necessary to kill
well she joins us now I'm glad to say
um thank you so much for coming on the
program again at such short notice I
wasn't expecting you to be interviewing
you again at three days later but I'm
very glad to have you
um if we can just start if if I may by
if you just remind viewers about what
happened to your daughter Ellie
um so Ellie was dating a fellow student
she was just 17 years old
um it was only a three-month
relationship but
um after a couple of months he became
controlling over her and suffocating and
she decided to end the relationship
um he then came to our house the
following day and he strangled her and
he stabbed her 13 times in the neck
um and then he just walked out of our
house as though nothing had happened
yeah it's just it is shocking and to
this day we still can't quite believe
it's happened
um so we had some hope after the Claire
Wave review that
um Overkill would finally be recognizing
the sentencing because a sentence in the
perpetrator got was just 12 and a half
years
um and I was absolutely devastated when
um on Monday I saw the letter that
Dominic Barr had sent to his colleagues
saying that they were considering just
an increasing censusin for two years you
know in one breath they're saying that
um that they they acknowledged it and
the horror of Overkill and the anguish
it causes to families and in the next
breath they're saying but we're gonna
and then we'll increase sentencing by
two years
[Music]
yeah and I mean it's just it's
heartbreaking all the campaigning we've
got we've been doing myself and Julie
Debbie to to try and level up this
sentence in between domestic homicides
and murders that happen in the street
and we were really hoping that you know
there were the 10-year difference would
be leveled up but it looks like it's not
going to be much more than two years and
if I could just talk a little bit about
the anguish that you go through as
parents
um we had to visit Ellie in the morgue
and they had to cover up her neck and
her face with bandages and plaster so
that we couldn't see the full extent of
her injuries
pop his parents have a 25-page document
detailing her 112 injuries
that's the anguish and the Heartbreak
that we live with every day knowing how
our beautiful girls were murdered
and you know just add in two years for
that is an absolute insult to us and I
think
Minister arga and Dominic Robb owe it to
us to have their meeting face to face
look in our eyes and explain to us how
they have come up with just adding two
years for the horrific nature of these
crimes
um and I I you know I'd be really
interesting to hear how they have come
up with that figure of just two two
years to add to the sentence
well that's a something that we can
certainly see if it happens or not if
you do get that face-to-face meeting
with those ministers do you feel that
you've been
misled perhapses perhaps too strong a
word but do you think you've been given
assurances or hope
that things would have been different
absolutely I mean we can't quite
understand why they're Consulting on
coercive controlling relationships
having a starting point of 25 years
um when 50 of domestic homicides
experience that but 60 of the domestic
homicides experienced Overkill so why
are they not Consulting on that being a
25-year starting point and and what
we've found with these murders is that
you can't rely on the judges to deliver
the correct sentence
um if in our case you know the judge
took two years off of Griffith's
sentence just because his grandparents
wrote a character reference because he'd
never been in trouble with the police
before which I think is pretty
irrelevant when you've just committed
the most heinous crime and for his
remorse letter well the details in his
remorse letter
um were not genuine remorse he didn't
explain why he did what he did he said I
hope one day I can explain myself well
to me that isn't genuine thought at all
and for those very negligible things he
got two years off his centers yet you
flip it the other way and for the most
horrific violent frenzied attack the
government are only prepared to add two
years it's all completely wrong and
that's why we were arguing to have it
actually written into law a 25 year
starting point for Overkill so that
judges can't get it wrong
you talk a bit about the difference
between domestic murders and murders on
the streets and I think it's just quite
important to talk about a little bit
more about what you mean by that do you
think that there has been I guess a
Prejudice perhaps a sort of anti-woman
bias in the system where if a murder is
committed within the home or within a
relationship it's somehow taken less
seriously
yeah totally these murders are not taken
with the seriousness they deserve you
know if you take a knife out on the
street and stab somebody once in the
park the starting point for sentencing
for that is 25 years
um if you obliterate somebody in the
home
um very violent friended attack the
starting point for censusin for that is
15 years and the justification for that
is that you can't prove it was
premeditated which quite honestly is
nonsense because the perpetrator doesn't
need to bring a weapon to the scene to
prove pre-meditation because they often
live with the victim they know where the
weapon is and many of these perpetrators
use their hands so you will never prove
pre-meditation if they're using their
hands because your hands are a weapon
and they travel with you
um it just diminishes the crime it's
insulting to women it's just so wrong
and we really thought this was a
watershed moment with this Claire Wave
review and all the talk of the
government about coming down hard and
violence against women and girls well
this is a bit of disappointment because
they're not are they
um so I think that we need to get around
the table with Minister arga and have a
honest and Frank conversation I have
contacted some MPS that I've had
dealings with in the past and the
general feeling is that this is wrong
um my own MP James Gray raised this at
all questions for the Justice Minister
yesterday and I I publicly thank him for
that and I've had some very positive
response from Caroline notes who is
going to um to raise this directly with
Minister Arthur okay well we're going to
keep pursuing your story with you we
it's a privilege to speak to you and I
know you were talking about the thing
that no parent wants to see which is
your child you know with bandages around
her neck and her face but we've been
looking at some beautiful pictures of
your daughter this evening she looks
happy she looks rhodium and you know I
can tell how loved she was so thank you
so much for being on the program again
we appreciate it thank you for following
it thank you very much
and yeah I think well she certainly is a
someone who's inspired me at the minute
and it feels like it's something that we
are going to continue to find out at the
Journey of that family and that bill as
well well in the meantime we can talk to
you at Sam coats and have a bit of a
Roundup shall we with our Deputy
political editor um it's difficult of
course to come off the back of an
interview like that where there's so
much emotion and so much import but we
were planning on talking a little bit
about Labor won't we and where they are
at the minute so they are still
somewhere between 15 and 20 points ahead
in the poll so there's no reason for
panic but I am just picking up the
slightest amount of concern in some
labor circles and it's for this reason
when you listen to any front Venture
come on uh your shows speaking the
comments listen to Kirsten this is a
very particular approach what they do is
they will respond to a government
announcement they will sidestep the
issue of principle or basically say but
of course this government is incompetent
it doesn't know what it's uh it's doing
and it's track record is terrible and
whether it's migration or brexit it
always takes that approach but that
seems to be fighting was it were the
last one that worked under Liz truss it
worked under Boris Johnson but now Rishi
seen that's been having a good few weeks
does it work under them and do they have
a clear enough policy offer I love what
you did with the chat GPT so what we've
done is we have just worked out uh we've
just asked ask for this intelligence to
work out what the labor Manifesto would
look like if you can't read this but you
get so this is what artificial
intelligence thinks the next UK labor
party manifested so this is sort of like
the Baseline they need to do better than
this but it assumes that the economic
policy of the labor party would be about
reducing inequality investing in public
services and supporting small business
they might focus on creating well-paid
jobs and minimum wage uh social policy
to help the homeless foreign policy to
prioritize peace that's the Baseline and
an AI bot can do it the question is do
labor front benches sound a lot
different to that that's a challenge and
the answer's not always not always you
think then what is your what is your
assessment to that then so this sounds
far too much like what labor politicians
are saying at the moment we'll put up on
social media put it on on the website
you can see what it says there I think
label needs to a lot better than a bot
and the question is can they in the
coming weeks and months I mean that does
sound like the killer question uh Sam on
Brutal form uh all sides getting it from
some coats uh tonight that's it for the
take we'll be back next week
[Music]
thank you